an intelligence expert has said that
these leaks are one of the four most
significant leaks of this Century Sky
News has reviewed more than 50 of the
documents one of them marked top secret
and not for sharing with foreign
Nationals shows Russian gains on the
front line and back but on the 1st of
March in great detail with troop
groupings and a number of casualties
we've blurred parts of this document or
take this stated a bit later the 23rd of
March it refers to the presence of a
small number of Western Special Forces
operating inside Ukraine without
specifying their activities or location
we've also blurred parts of the document
which are confidential now this suggests
that the UK had the largest contingent
of Special Forces 50 soldiers that's
more than four other countries combined
that's despite the British government
never announcing the deployment of
Special Forces within Ukraine and then
there are scores of other revelations in
these documents the US apparently warned
that Ukraine's long-awaited offensive
might only yield limited territorial
gain means it also warned that Ukraine
was in danger of running out of missiles
for its air defense systems we don't
know if that is still the case or then
there's this the president of Egypt
allegedly drawing up plans to send 40
000 Rockets to Russia in secret to avoid
problems with the West so it is an
extremely significant leap this wasn't
apparently a whistlebler determined to
get as much attention as possible
instead the documents were posted to a
small group on Discord and online
platform originally developed for video
Gamers apparently to impress people
inside that group and they stayed there
for weeks unnoticed but the documents
leaked on for one group in Discord to
another bigger one look at how one
person announced it they what they said
is here have some leaks documents from
that they went to the 410 forum and onto
the messaging app telegram before making
their way to Twitter and the world's
attention a government including the UK
Ukraine and South Korea have said that
the leagues contain inaccurate or
potentially doctored information but the
reaction of the US government the arrest
and charging of Dr Sarah gives every
reason to believe that much of what they
describe is authentic